Consider the following table
of values for a linear function
f of x is equal to mx plus b
and an exponential function g
of x is equal to a
times r to the x.
Write the equation
for each function.
And so they give us,
for each x-value,
what f of x is and
what g of x is.
And we need to figure out the
equation for each function
and type them in over here.
So I copy and
pasted this problem
on my little scratchpad.
So let's first think
about the linear function.
And to figure out the
equation of a line
or a linear function
right over here,
you really just need two points.
And I always like to use the
situation when x equals 0
because that makes
it very clear what
the y-intercept is going to be.
So, for example, we
can say that f of 0
is going to be equal
to m times 0 plus b.
Or this is just going
to be equal to b.
And they tell us that
f of 0 is equal to 5.
b is equal to 5.
So we immediately know
that this b right over here
is equal to 5.
Now, we just have
to figure out the m.
We have to figure out
the slope of this line.
So just as a little bit
of a refresher on slope,
the slope of this line is
going to be our change in y--
or our change in our function
I guess we could say,
if we say that this
y is equal to f
of x-- over our change in x.
And actually, let me
write it that way.
We could write
this as our change
in our function
over our change in x
if you want to look
at it that way.
So let's look at
this first change
in x when x goes from 0 to 1.
So we finish at 1.
We started at 0.
And f of x finishes
at 7 and started at 5.
So when x is 1, f of x is 7.
When x is 0, f of x is 5.
And we get a change
in our function of 2
when x changes by 1.
So our m is equal to 2.
And you see that.
When x increases by 1, our
function increases by 2.
So now we know the
equation for f of x.
f of x is going to be equal
to 2 times 2x plus b, or 5.
So we figured out
what f of x is.
Now we need to figure
out what g of x is.
So g of x is an
exponential function.
And there's really two things
that we need to figure out.
We need to figure
out what a is, and we
need to figure out what r is.
And let me just rewrite that.
So we know that g of x--
maybe I'll do it down here.
g of x is equal to a
times r to the x power.
And if we know what g of 0 is,
that's a pretty useful thing.
Because r to the 0th
power, regardless
of what r is-- or
I guess we could
assume that r is not equal to 0.
People can debate what
0 to the 0 power is.
But if r is any
non-zero number, we
know that if you raise it
to the 0 power, you get 1.
And so that
essentially gives us a.
So let's just write that down.
g of 0 is a times r to
the 0 power, which is just
going to be equal
to a times 1 or a.
And they tell us what g of
0 is. g of 0 is equal to 3.
So we know that a is equal to 3.
So so far, we know that our g
of x can be written as 3 times r
to the x power.
So now we can just use any
one of the other values
they gave us to solve for r.
For example, they tell us
that g of 1 is equal to 2.
So let's write
that down. g of 1,
which would be 3 times r to
the first power, or just 3--
let me just write it.
It could be 3 times
r to the first power,
or we could just write
that as 3 times r.
They tell us that g
of 1 is equal to 2.
So we get 3 times
r is equal to 2.
Or we get that r
is equal to 2/3.
Divide both sides of
this equation by 3.
So r is 2/3.
And we're done.
g of x is equal to 3 times 2/3.
Actually, let me just
write it this way.
3 times 2/3 to the x power.
You could write it that way
if you want, any which way.
So 3 times 2/3 to the x power,
and f of x is 2x plus 5.
So let's actually
just type that in.
So f of x is 2x plus 5.
And we can verify that that's
the expression that we want.
And g of x is 3 times 2
over 3 to the x power.
And let me just verify that
that's what I did there.
I have a short memory.
All right.
Yeah, that looks right.
Let's check our answer.
And we got it right.